auch wenn sich das total behindert
anhört macht das einfach und da macht
ihr folgendes etwas klappt ist
willkommen beim neuen video und zwar
habe ich letztens folgenden kommentar
gelesen ich kann ja mal kurz ein bin
irgendwie steht aber drin von wegen
ja was soll man so oder worüber sondern
und einen jungen schreiben wenn man ihn
halt so gerade kennen lernt das problem
kenne ich selber mehr sofort vor zwei
oder drei jahren aber ich habe mir
gedacht warum machst du nicht wirklich
einfach ein video so ist meine meinung
wenn ihr die nicht vertreten ist das
überhaupt kein problem wenn ihr andere
meinung seid könnt ihr gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
aber ich will gar nicht angelaufen und
ich würde sagen wir legen direkt mal los
so ich habe das in mehreren videos schon
angesprochen und zwar es ist ja
eigentlich scheiße wenn man selber immer
die person ist die den anderen anschlägt
oder die personen die halt immer sofort
antwortet deswegen erstmal so ganz
locker vorweg wenn das der fall ist dann
schreibt wirklich nicht immer direkt an
oder antwortet direkt weil ich habe dazu
schon so oft gesagt meiner meinung da
sorgt dass so ein bisschen für das
interesse und dann ist das manchmal so
dass ihr vielleicht der anderen person
egal ob sitzen junge oder mädchen songs
geht auch wenn es keine hand zum teil
aber es ist wirklich so dass ist vor
allem jetzt gerade wenn man sich noch
nicht lange kennen einfach so schreibt
man weiß nicht worüber man schreiben
sollen dann kommt halt manchmal einfach
dazu dass die ganze zeit nur so
hässliche smileys hin und her geschickt
werden kennt ihr alle oder das weitere
das ist ja auch oft so dass man sich
unbedingt mit der person mal treffen
möchte aber man sich halt nicht traut
die personen danach zu fragen und das
ist halt auf beiden seiten meistens so
ja das ist ja eigentlich ziemlich
scheiße oder nicht deswegen meiner
meinung nach ich betone noch mal meiner
meinung nach nicht dass jetzt wieder
irgendwelche mensch in den kommentaren
ankommen und mich voll blöd von der
seite genommen und ich dann meinen muss
ja natürlich ist es immer sehr schwer
was zu finden was heißt sehr schwer es
ist halt schwer was zu finden wobei man
weiß das ist in anderen wirklich
interessiert und nicht so dass ich habe
es in meinem letzten video mal
angesprochen wenn ich ihn wenn die
irgendwie von pferden folge lammert
werde dann sind fünf juroren jetzt kommt
erstmal sondern generell
generell gibt es das wort über auch
jetzt kommt erstmal lückenfüller den man
halt generell oder worüber man halt
generell
schreiben kann und zwar dann merkte
andere als eklig da besteht so interesse
so understand und zwar die heutzutage
jeder mensch chat und selbst ist ja
eigentlich so ein bisschen so wenn man
so snap das ist ja viel cooler mit
bildern und so und frag einfach nach
snap chat oder stellt einfach fragen von
wegen wie viele freundin hattest du
schon worauf stehst du so weit das ist
eigentlich das ist meiner meinung nach
so will ich keine ahnung wie ich das
sagen soll also das dann ist man
wirklich so ein gespräch drin im schnitt
drin
ihr wisst was ich meine ja und ihr wollt
euch dann wahrscheinlich unbedingt mit
der person treffen frank es am besten
nicht direkt sondern lasst euch erstmal
zeit erstmals frei bist ja auch dann zu
quälen aber wenn man sich da wirklich
denkt okay jetzt kann ich eigentlich mal
fragen weil der andere ich fragte die
andere frank ich halt und ich verstehe
nicht warum immer der junge fragen musst
du eigentlich scheißegal ich vertrete
jetzt heutzutage so die meinung es ist
eigentlich immer am besten so direkt zu
franjo hat sarah borgward mit mir zu
machen ein bisschen saufen kiffen etc in
den spaß so ward nicht einfach ein eis
essen gehen
ihr wisst schon aber ich weiß auch dass
wenn man so 13 14 ist vielleicht auch
schon 15 da ist hat noch nicht ganz so
zum teil auch mit dem selbstbewusstsein
lebens wenn ich über das ist bei jedem
anders
aber man traut sie halt nicht immer
direkt natürlich es gibt wahrscheinlich
auf 13 jährige trauen sich das schon so
direkt einfach zu fragen aber es gibt
auch viele die traunsee zeit nicht und
da kommt jetzt ein trick ins spiel den
ich eventuell auch mal angewendet habe
halt früher nicht heute ja und zwar wenn
man halt mal wieder da sollen so eine
lücke drin ist man weiß halt nicht
worüber man schreiben soll
dann schreibt ihr als einfach mal egal
ob mädchen oder junge pass auf ich
google jetzt einfach mal nach
gesprächsthemen auch wenn sich das total
behindert anhört macht das einfach und
dann macht ihr folgendes es gibt nämlich
so viele bilder dastehen so
gesprächsthemen drauf auch wenn die
total scheiße langweilig sind ganz unten
steht halt immer spricht oder schreibt
darüber ob ihr mal was zusammen
unternehmen möchte ich packe euch
einfach mal ein link zu einem bild und
in die video beschreibung dort euch das
oder machten screenshot wenn ihr altgold
und dann guck mal ob das klappt ohne
scheint das muss eigentlich zu 95
klappen und bitte treibt ihr einfach mal
so in die kommentare ob es geklappt hat
oder nicht auch wenn ihr das jetzt erst
in der woche testet macht einfach die
kommentare wird mich mega interessieren
laut vorgärten ja heute keine ahnung ob
das video irgendwie ein bisschen kurz
geraten ist kommt mir gerade vor auf
jeden fall in vancouver als eingebildet
mit gekonnten cooles video wieder texas
auf jeden fall fünftel auf meinem zettel
hier oben links geht es weiter mit
meinem letzten video das war hier so
eine 14-jährige war ein bisschen
abgetönt abgedreht zeigt dass man auch
wirklich freuen ansonsten mit 1500
schönen tag noch